[Music]
well hello dear friends welcome to this
q a program i'd like to know we're glad
that you decided to join us today we
have some very captivating questions
i'd like to give you the address where
you can send us your questions and we
will do the research and if it's
possible we will find an answer for your
question the address that you can go to
is tv at some tv dot org
once again tv
at some tv dot org
and we will answer the questions as they
come in
and we hope that the answer the answers
will be satisfactory i have with me
pastor daniel miranda he is the
associate speaker one of the associate
speakers for secrets unsealed
his
specific
task here is to coordinate the spanish
speaking programs but he also does a lot
of english programs because he's been
blessed
with the ability to speak both languages
and so what we want to do is to have a
word of prayer
and then after the word of prayer we'll
get into several questions that we have
for today so pastor miranda you're going
to have the word of prayer so let's pray
let's pray
dear heavenly father
thank you lord for this program
thank you for your people who send their
questions
and i pray lord that as we
seek to answer these questions from the
word of god
that you may direct this study and that
we may say only what is revealed in your
word in the name of jesus we pray
amen amen amen
well we have uh our first question for
today that comes from jariel aponte
figueroa
and
his question is
if satan knew god
like no one else and still decided to
rebel
what hope do we have
and then he questions about
how can you see
and be so close of such goodness and
such glory and decide to get apart from
it it doesn't make sense please help me
understand
this
well the bottom line is
that lucifer uses freedom of choice yes
to choose wrongly
now can we explain that
no
how could a holy being
who
had never sinned
he was totally righteous
suddenly
decide to exercise his freedom of choice
to go against god
we can't answer that question
yeah ellen white in fact says that if we
answered that question god would
ultimately be guilty of sin correct
so
this is one area where silence
is golden
where uh we need to just
not pursue it amen
yes in fact the bible says or
trying to explain the entrance of sin in
the world the bible calls it the mystery
of iniquity it is a mystery we cannot
understand it we cannot
completely explain it in ii
thessalonians chapter 2 verse 7 we read
about the mystery of iniquity it says
for the mystery of iniquity does already
work
only he who now letteth will let until
he be taken out of the way so the first
part of that verse says
speaks about the mystery of iniquity and
if it is a mystery
then
there are things that we cannot explain
now
there's another mystery the mystery of
godliness right yes and we can't explain
everything relating to the mystery of
godliness exactly
there's a lot of mystery involved there
sure so we need just to have faith
in what god says
trust his word
by the way ellen white also says that
the that the origin of sin is a mystery
uh in the book great controversy i think
it's page 492
uh she says that the the origin of sin
is a mystery correct and we usually
think of you know how
god creating lucifer caused the mess
that we're in right now
but we don't realize that the entrance
of sin the fact that god allowed lucifer
to exercise his freedom of choice to go
against him how it has impacted the
godhead
you know god has suffered intensely
because he allowed lucifer to
exercise his freedom of choice
to choose to go against god and against
his law
yeah the only way to have
a kingdom
or a universe that would
where love and justice and righteousness
would reign
is
giving the creatures the free will the
free exercise of their will now that's
uh that's risky uh
it is a two-edged sword because
um we see it that
in the case of lucifer he chose to go
against god but that doesn't mean that
god is the culprit he is guilty of it
we are given freedom of choice
and
but the argument that god uses
to preserve the harmony of the universe
is love he wants us to choose to love
him because he is love we love him
because he first loved us so that is his
argument and and through this great
controversy this is going to be a
textbook for the whole universe
that
uh sin is not a choice sin brings a lot
of suffering the sin brings a lot of
pain and you know we have a lot of
advantages in the fact that we have the
scriptures yes we have the example of
christ
becoming incarnate and revealing the
love of god
you know lucifer's guilt is far greater
than any
one else's guilt because he was in the
very presence
of god
and so
he beheld the glory of god
and the goodness of god and the mercy of
god and he still decided to exercise his
freedom of choice to choose evil
but once again
god is not to blame for our wrong use of
freedom of choice we are guilty of
making the wrong choices amen
okay i think that that pretty well
answers the question now
here's another this is um
you know a question that can easily be
answered uh it's also by the same person
by ariela ponte figuero and by the way
he says that he's from the beautiful
island of puerto rico
la isla velencanto the enchanting island
and this is the question which spanish
concordance
do we recommend so
what can we say about bible concordances
well there are three
um
basic or the most common concordances
that theologians and bible students use
one is strong's concordance
and um we have also crudence concordance
and young's concordance now i like uh
the saying that the theologians have
about it um that we were mentioning
behind the behind the cameras yeah the
cam in the seminary they used to say
uh young's is for the young
crudence is for the crew
and strong's is further strong
[Laughter]
and you know i use strong's but i also
use young's concordance because
young young's is an analytical
concordance
and strong's is just basically it gives
you the numbers and the words in hebrew
and greek all the times that they appear
in scripture so you know i would say use
a combination of strongs and youngs
crudence is the one that uh william
miller
and so that's a very ancient one
and uh it has uh it's a good concordance
but uh
strong's
and young's are exhaustive
concordances in other words they cover
all of the bases
and i think they
those are also in spanish yeah at least
i know strong i have strong in spanish
and
maybe young's concordance is also in
spanish
but i have to double check that yeah i'm
not sure you know when i was teaching
theology in colombia
they
they had a doc a volume that was called
concordance
concordance of the sacred scriptures
and that's the only one that was
available back then
but you know since then there's been a
lot because of computers make it makes
it a lot easier to classify things uh
it's very well possible that young's and
uh and strong's are available now yeah i
don't know about crudeness but anyway i
hope that helps you just have to make
your choice
so what's our next question
our next question is in regards to the
god head
this question comes from wilex
jakobi
and the question
is about the difference between the
godhead and the trinity
could you explain to me this question
are these words equal
well uh basically
it all depends who you are
some people uh
despise the word trinity
the word that is used in the bible is
godhead in romans chapter one
for the three persons of the godhead
um
i personally do not like the word
trinity
not because it's a bad word
the word trinity means simply
three in unity yes try unity
but the reason i don't like the word is
first of all because it's not the word
that the bible uses
and secondly because it comes bathed
in roman catholic tradition correct the
way the roman catholic church uses it
you know there's another couple of words
that we don't use in the adventist
church that are good biblical words for
example the word eucharist correct
no the roman catholic church calls what
we call communion the eucharist the
eucharist it's a beautiful word
it means to give thanks
in fact it's used in conjunction with
the lord's supper
why don't we call it why don't we call
it uh the eucharist when we go to
participate of communion
well because it's bathed in roman
catholic theology
they believe that
jesus uh body the the host becomes the
real body of jesus and
you know the grape juice or the wine
becomes his real blood so we don't use
the word eucharist even though it's a
good biblical word
you know another word that we don't use
for our pastors is bishop
once again because of the roman catholic
connotation with the word bishop we use
the word pastor we use the word elder
so i think it's best to stick by the
biblical terminology which is the
godhead
and you know
how can we explain the godhead
um
it's not as mysterious as people think
it is
basically the idea of the godhead is
that there are three persons
in perfect unity
and they're distinct persons
that are in perfect harmony
they have the same attributes they have
the same powers
they have the same wisdom
in other words there's there are three
persons but they're one in terms of
unity
and in the bible we have examples of
this
for example uh it says in genesis that
when god married adam and eve he said
you're not two anymore you're one well
there were two
but god says you're not two you're one
also at the tower of babel
those who were building the tower you
know
god said the people are one well they
weren't one person
and then you have in john 17 where jesus
is praying for the disciples he says
that you will make them one
as you and i are one so
it's not that all uh 11 disciples were
going to jump into one body and become
one person no it's just a case of
all being in unity one with the other
amen i think that's where the confusion
is because when the bible speaks of
unity or oneness
it doesn't necessarily
mean
in number but in essence in quality in
character and the best illustration
is the marriage relation
the actually the same word they had in
hebrew in genesis 2 24 where it says
that there shall be one flesh it is the
same word that is used in deuteronomy 6
4 the shema
the lord our god is one
god so it is in that
context with that connotation that god
is one
i agree
with you passover in regards to the use
of the word trinity that we we as
adventists understand even if we use the
word trinity we have the biblical uh
concept of the trinity
but since it is bathed with with
catholic theology
some of us prefer not to use it
uh what do catholics teach about trinity
i have a few quotes here
there is one that comes from my catholic
faith the manual of religion luis
bishop of
kingshangar
and this quote says
god the father eternally knows himself
this is even aberrant
and continues to know himself
copula that is copulates with himself
and continues to follow himself and thus
continues to bring forth the sun in
continual birth
god the father and god the son continue
to love each other
and their delight in each other
continues to bring forth the spirit of
love
god the holy spirit or the holy ghost
in a similar way fire has light and
color as long as there is fire it
continues to produce light
as long as there is fire with light
there is produced color i mean this is
very
uh
this comes from paganism yeah the idea
of of three gods you see it in the
babylonian religion you see it in the
egyptian religion three gods and
unusually there is a female god and the
relationship between the male god and
the female god brings forth the
the the third god
of the pagan godhead so they borrowed
this from paganism and now apply it to
the biblical godhead yeah and because of
this connotation
we prefer not to use some of us to use
the word trinity but if a pastor uses it
don't think that he is a roman catholic
it is because the word
uh has become so common
in
trinitarian churches and movements
that many people prefer to use trinity
yeah in other words we're not critical
of individuals who use the word trinity
exactly within the seventh-day adventist
church as long as we don't have the
understanding of what you just read yes
you know the problem that i have with
the roman catholic view of the trinity
is that it's very philosophical
it was developed in a period when when
uh secular philosophy was infiltrating
the church
and um
council of nicaea yeah there's there's
certain terminology like for example
theologians talk about the economic
trinity
and you know they use terminology that's
not in the bible to describe the
relationship of the father son and holy
spirit
in this quotation this individual is
saying that
there is fire there is light and there
is color
so in the same way there is the father
the son and the holy spirit
the problem that i have with that idea
is
and with other analogies for example
some use the analogy of body soul and
spirit so yeah father son and holy
spirit uh some use the example of an egg
you know you have the yolk you have the
yellow part and you have the shell
and then you have some that can compare
the godhead with water there's a liquid
solid and then there's steam
the problem with that idea
is
that
each member of the godhead is fully and
completely god amen
with the egg as an example
the shell is part of the egg
the yolk is part of the egg
and the white part is part of the egg
but with the godhead
all three
are fully and completely they have all
of the attributes and all of the powers
of god amen uh and and so uh analogies
are very limited
in their helpfulness in discussing the
godhead there will always be
an element of mystery
in the godhead correct
it is
a very
complex
topic
and i think
this answers the question in regards to
the difference between the godhead and
the trinity i certainly hope that it's
helpful
i think you have a series on on on the
godhead right revisiting
revisiting the goals so that would be
good if
if you can watch that series again by
pastor bohr i watched it that was
powerful that was such a blessing in a
time when the
godhead especially the holy spirit was
being challenged and i think
the lord used you to produce that series
yeah uh basically the series uh is um
you know showing the texts that speak of
god as one
and other verses that speak
of god as many
and how do you coordinate those two
groups of texts
and then there's a study in ezekiel
chapter one as well
where you have that
chariot and you know ha
hands under the wings and one sitting on
the throne you actually have the godhead
there in ezekiel chapter 1. and then
also there's another presentation in
that series on the role of angels
in the godhead
so
i would recommend those who are watching
if you want to
go more in depth amen just make sure
that you get that series that's called
revisiting the godhead amen okay so now
we have another question um on first
corinthians 13. yep
so this is also from our brother
giariella ponte figueroa
first corinthians 13
there are several questions one is the
first one if you stop loving someone
does it mean you never loved him
so let's try to answer that first
question
well i would say
no it means that you don't love him now
it doesn't mean that you didn't love
that person before
love is uh continuous
ellen white says love is like a plant
that needs to be water
daily or else it will die
so when we compare love
with a plant that needs care it needs
sun it needs air it needs water it needs
good nutrients
so that the plant can continue
to grow
same with love we need to cultivate that
love daily and the true source of love
is god when we stop loving
that means that
we stop
receiving the love of god right
because the love of god
flows into the heart through the holy
spirit amen and then it flows out
towards others exactly so you know
really
if you stop loving someone doesn't mean
you never love them well lucifer before
he sinned undoubtedly loved god correct
but then when he chose to go against
god's law
he lost his love i can say quite safely
today that satan does not love god
oh yeah he lost the love because of his
choice
uh so and the next question has
something to do with that specifically
is love a decision or a mindset attitude
or what is it
love is a decision and at the same time
a principle
you choose
to love
but you you need to have enough reason
for that
what arguments does god use in order to
woe us to him in order to make us love
him first of all he's our creator
secondly he's our redeemer
thirdly he is our provider
he
provides all that we need and he has
shown us his love
in every aspect of our lives
through nature we can read the about the
love of god in the word of god ellen y
says also in the book steps to christ
that in the tender and human
relationships of life
god reveals himself to us
so
it depends on how we respond
to those manifestations of love
obviously love is a choice
because i chose to love my wife yes
and not other women amen love other
women as christians
but not the kind of marital love
so so
love is a choice that a person makes so
if you can choose to love you can also
choose not to love
and can you
choose not to love someone after you
have chosen to love them the answer to
that question in the bible is clearly
yes you can lose your love
and i think it's very important that
love is a principle
um
you know many people confuse
feelings and emotions with love
the problem is when you depend on your
feelings or emotions
to love someone
when the feelings and emotions change
then the so-called love changes as well
correct so in that sense love is a
principle it's something that's planted
in the heart it's something that remains
no matter whether you feel an emotion or
you don't feel an emotion because it's a
principle that god implants in the heart
and first corinthians says it um if we
if we read a few passages from there
you see that this love is beyond human
love
and i like the word that is used in the
in the king james charity or love
suffers long and is kind
charity envy is not
charity banteth not itself is not puffed
up does not behave itself and seemingly
secret not her own is not easily
provoked think of not evil
uh i like verse seven beareth all things
believeth all things hopeth all things
and endureth all things bears all things
never faileth verse eight
in the good and the bad in in richness
and in health
in poverty or
in all circumstances
right this love
is always the same
in sickness and in health in prosperity
or adversity like the marriage vows
exactly
and that shows that love is a principle
the surrounding circumstances do not
determine whether you love it's an
internal thing amen and that's why in
adversity and in prosperity
the love is the same
and in sickness and in health the love
is the same because it's a principle
that doesn't change depending on the
circumstances and depending on your
emotions
and you know one of the problems that
young people have these days
is that they get married
uh because of emotion
rather than married because of principle
and so i always tell young people make
sure
that love goes
through your brain to your heart
don't let love go directly to the heart
because the heart is deceitful above all
things
go let it go into your mind
check to see if the person is committed
to the lord if the person loves the lord
that the person is committed to
to the seventh adventist message
and
and then make your decision based on
those principles rather than just on the
emotions or the looks or the words that
that person speaks it has to be based on
a principle that god implants in the
heart amen
jesus is the perfect example of love
for me it's mind-boggling when jesus was
on the cross
and after
all the things he had to go through he
was mistreated he was falsely accused
and then on the cross jesus
said forgive them for they know they do
not know what they do yeah
so jesus
did not condition for his love for those
who love him actually jesus said right
if you only love those who love you
that's what the gentiles do right
the true love of god
is even manifested to the enemies
and that's where
you start seeing the perfect love of god
if you only love if you're only kind
when others are kind to you and if you
love others when others love you that's
what the gentiles do yeah that's right
in fact in that passage
in matthew chapter 5 in the parallel in
luke chapter 6
god says there
be therefore perfect
as your heavenly father is perfect and
in context it means to love
impartially exactly jew gentile no
matter who it is
you love
not because the person is lovable
but because you have love as a principle
in the heart amen and the third question
here is if love is a decision
can you decide to stop loving someone
and still say that you loved them
i believe that the answer to that
question would be
yes
you can say that you still love them
if
the point comes where you stop loving
someone yes
well very very good question
this
topic of love is very very profound i
like it it's one of my favorites
actually it's one of the main themes
that we find in scripture
we want to encourage you to
continue
with our
program following us on internet on our
channel send your questions to the email
tv at suntv.org
and we will do our best to answer your
questions
god
blesses you and
may we see you next time
[Music]
you